une file d'attenté comme s'il s'agissait
de faire ses courses à l'ouverture des
magasins pourtant pas d'aliments à
acheter ou de papier toilette mais du
sang et des plaquettes collecter un bel
élan de solidarité à rambouillet comme
partout en france l'établissement
français du sang maintient ses
opérations confinement au pas les
besoins restent les mêmes dix sept mille
dons sont nécessaires tous les jours en
ile de france
je rappelle que nous sommes un
établissement de santé
et quand l'état donc nous nous
continuons à collecter que les malades
eux sont toujours malades et que
certes locaux vides tourner partons
maintenant mais les malades eux s'ils
n'ont pas leurs produits sanguins il
risque vraiment d'être très très mal
considéré comme vital et indispensable
par l'état le don du sang ne requiert
qu'une attestation dûment remplies c'est
alors l'occasion de réussir une
opération rare en ce moment sauver des
vies tout en sortant de chez soi en
toute légalité et l'habitude de mener
mon sens là en plus ils ont beaucoup de
contraintes pour pouvoir désinfecter
mais c'est vraiment superbement fait je
sais rester sur le site de la mairie
c'était possible de sortir pour cette
raison donc je les fais des précautions
qui sont demandés je pense que c'est
possible
on a très bien accueilli ici comme dans
les supermarchés ou chez votre boucher
toutes les précautions sanitaires sont
respectés distance de 1 mètre minimum
entre chaque donneur et désinfection des
lieux pour éviter tout risque de
contamination
les professionnels en des masques non
pas pour se protéger mais pour éviter
puisqu'il son contact de nombreuses
personnes qui peuvent être malade ça
peut être le co vide mais ça peut être
la grippe ou autre chose sur les
surfaces de contact de nettoyer plus
régulièrement les surfaces de contact
s'est du coup une prise en charge un
petit peu plus plus longue
surtout quand les donneurs finalement
son rendez-vous en cinq heures durant
cette collecte 105 personnes ont donné
leur sang dont 10 pour la première fois
si les réserves de le ffs sont encore
jugées suffisantes elle pour une plus
l'être en cas de confinement prolonger
la mobilisation est donc essentiel
plusieurs collectes sont prévues ces
prochains jours dans les yvelines